LAGOS MOLNAR: In today's
world, video is everywhere.
You are an app developer, and
you want to wow your users.
But how do you create the
detailed, fine-tuned media
magic that you have envisioned?
I am Lajos, from the Android
Video Framework Team,
and I'm going to talk about
how to create great, even
impressive multimedia
experiences on Android.
Sure, Android has great
high-level media APIs.
But if you want to do something
other than playing or capturing
video, or you need a
feature that is not
supported by MediaPlayer
or MediaRecorder,
you will need to
get down and dirty
with the nuts and
bolts of Android
Media-- the low-level APIs.
They consist of
the MediaCodec that
is used to both decode--
compress audio and video--
and to encode raw
audio and video.
MediaExtractor parses
media container files
into audio and video packets.
Conversely, MediaMuxer packages
audio and video packets
into media container.
MediaCrypto and
MediaDRM are used
to decrypt protected
media content
and to manage the
digital rights.
You can do everything that
MediaPlayer and MediaRecorder
does using the low level APIs.
I know it, because we did it.
For example, to
build a media player,
you need two MediaCodec
objects and a MediaExtractor
to parse the individual
audio and video packets out
of the data source.
To play back secure content,
you will need a MediaDRM object
to manage the secure session.
And you will need to
provide a MediaCrypto
object to the video decoder.
You can implement
MediaRecorder using
two MediaCodecs
and a MediaMuxer.
In fact, you can
build a wide variety
of multimedia applications.
And, might I add,
quite cool ones.
Then you combine
these media blocks
with others, such as
textures and texture shaders.
For example, this is how you
could do video editing as it is
done in Auto Awesome
Movie in Google+.
Decode the two source
videos onto GL Textures.
Composite them
using GLES Shaders
onto the input surface
of a video encoder.
Viola.
That was easy.
So how does MediaCodec work?
MediaCodec, at its core,
is a signal processor
that produces output
data from input data.
It is processing
data asynchronously
and uses a set of input
and output buffers.
At a simplistic level, the
client requests an empty input
buffer, fills it up
with data, and sends it
to the codec for processing.
The codec uses up the
data and transforms it
into one of its
empty output buffers.
Finally, the client requests
a filled output buffer,
consumes its contents, and
sends it back to the codec.
The real operation of a codec
is a little more complex
as each of these operations
is happening in parallel.
Also, codecs that
produce raw video buffers
can be connected to a surface.
Let's go over the
states of MediaCodec.
When you create a
codec, it starts
in the uninitialized state.
First, you need to configure it.
When you call Start, the codec
moves to the flushed state
where it holds all the buffers.
As soon as you dequeue
an input buffer,
the codec moves to
the running state.
It spends most of its
useful life here processing
input buffers,
generating output.
If you queue an input buffer
with the End of Stream flag,
the codec moves to the
End of Stream state.
Here it no longer accepts
further input buffers,
but still generates output
until the End of Stream buffer
is reached.
You can move back to
the flushed states
from any of the executing
states by calling Flush.
Or call Stop to go back
to the configure state.
If you call Reset
from any state,
the codec moves back to
the uninitialized state.
On rare occasions, the
codec may encounter an error
and move to the error state.
This is communicated
using an invalid return
value from a queueing operation
or sometimes via an exception.
Call Reset to make the
codec usable again.
After you finish
using a codec, you
have to release it
by calling Release.
Boom.
By default, codecs
use [? buffers ?]
for both input and output data.
However, video codecs
can be configured
to use hardware accelerated
surface buffers for raw video.
This is the preferred
mode to operate hardware
accelerated video
codecs as it allows
them to work without memcpy.
In either mode, MediaCodec
uses buffer indices
to refer to buffers.
You get the index of
an empty input buffer
by calling Dequeue Input Buffer.
You can then fill
the buffer with data,
apply a time stamp or flags,
and sand in to the codec
by using Queue Input Buffer.
To get a filled output buffer,
call Dequeue Output Buffer
to get its index.
Note how to time stamp is
propagated from the input
buffer.
If using [? buffers, ?] you
can then process the data
and release the buffer by
calling Release Output Buffer.
A couple of cautions.
Although buffers are referred
to by indices in a buffer array,
not all indices may be
valid so there is really
no indication of the
number of buffers used.
All output buffers
are read only.
You should only access
a buffer by your holding
onto it with Dequeue and
Queue, or Release Buffer calls.
Though buffers are
handled asynchronously,
release each buffer promptly.
Doing otherwise may
stall some codecs.
As mentioned before, you
can set up a video encoder
to process hardware
accelerated surface input.
You do this by calling Create
Input Surface after Configure.
Pass this surface
to the producer
of the video frames which will
now directly talk to the codec.
Similarly to the
normal operation,
the producer will request
and empty input buffer,
fill it with data,
apply your time stamp,
and send it back to the
codec for processing.
When you want to stop
the encoding session,
call Signal End of Input Stream
to apply the end of stream flag
to effectively the
last frame received.
Likewise, you can
configure video decoders
to use hardware
accelerated output buffers
by specifying an output
surface in Configure.
Use the familiar
Dequeue Output Buffer
to get the index of a
filled output buffer.
However, in contrast to
[? buffers, ?] you cannot
inspect the contents of
surface output buffers.
You can only decide
whether or not
to send a buffer on
to the output surface.
To discard it, call Release
Output Buffer with render
set to False.
Or sets render to
True to display
the buffer on the
output surface.
In the L Developer Preview,
the added support to optionally
set the time stamp of a surface
buffer about to be rendered.
If set, some buffer consumers
will wait for a time stamp
to pass before
using that buffer.
We have recently
added a few features
to make MediaCodec more useful.
One of these, as
demonstrated briefly before,
is the ability to
precisely schedule
the display of video frames.
Up until now, A/V sync has
been difficult to achieve.
With the addition of
surface time stamp
support in MediaCodec and
high-resolution time stamp
support an AudioTrack, this
is now straightforward.
Scheduling of video frames
only works on surface view.
Use the precise audio time stamp
to calculate the exact system
time when you want the video
frame to appear on the display.
Then set the time stamp by
calling Release Output Buffer
about two VSYNC periods prior.
The frame will be shown
at the first VSYNC
after the requested time stamp.
Another recent
improvement to MediaCodec
is the support for
adaptive playback.
Adapted playback is an optional
feature of video decoders
that enables seamless change
in resolution during playback.
Whereas the client can
start to feed the decoder,
input video frames of a new
resolution, and the resolution
of the output buffers
change automatically
and without a significant gap.
It is only supported if
the codec is configured
to use hardware accelerated
surface buffers.
If a codec does not
support adaptive playback,
you can still change
the resolution.
First, mark the last frame
of the old resolution
with an End of Stream flag.
Then wait until all
frames are decoded.
Then stop the codec,
or simply flush it
if using API level 19 or higher.
Then configure it for
the new resolution.
Finally, start the codec again.
Wow.
And I used to think
that was convenient.
Before you can rely on the
adaptive playback features,
you need to verify
that it is supported
by the codec you are using by
calling [INAUDIBLE] Feature
Supported API.
You enable adaptive playback
during codec configuration
using two special keys,
max width and max height.
These for a hint for the
maximum resolution that
has to be supported
by the codec.
If the configuration
succeeds, the codec
is expected to switch
resolutions smaller
than the hinge in
a seamless fashion.
Switching to larger resolutions
is still possible dynamically,
but it may not be seamless.
Also, if you try to switch
to a resolution that is not
supported by the codec, it
will enter its error state.
A word of advice,
to conserve memory,
use the smallest
resolution hinge
required for your use case.
To change the video resolution
while the codec is running,
simply cue a SYNC frame
using Queue Input Buffer.
A SYNC frame is a
special key frame
that also contains the
configuration change
parameters.
For H264, this means
that the SPS and PPS
are supplied together with the
IDR frame in a single buffer.
Woof.
That was a lot of information.
We have published a streaming
video player example
on the developer website
that demonstrates
the use of the low level APIs
as well as adaptive playback.
There's also video
by [? Ollie ?]
that describes this
sample in detail.
Be sure to check them out.
And for those of
you who want more,
the low-level
media APIs are also
available in the Android NDK.
These CAPIs mimic
the Java ones and are
available for both 32 and
64-bit native binaries.
Sweet.
With that, I must say farewell.
I leave you with the challenge
of building something
fantastic for your users using
the Media Building Blocks.
For more information, visit
the Android developer website
for API reference, guides,
and sample applications.
Thank you for your time.